parce que tel un chien non match a
atteint 2 chats je gère t cha
probablement scandale mais regardent de
plus en plus de français abandonnent
leurs chiens morosité économique aidant
ils ne peuvent plus assumer les dépenses
qu'entraînent les chiens surtout envie
une étude récente de l'insee ne confirme
en moyenne et par an pour un chien les
français dépensent légèrement plus que
pour un enfant
une des raisons de ce chiffre est la
diminution du nombre de foyers modestes
possédant un chien et l'augmentation de
ces même nombre dans les classes les
plus aisées
nous remarquons une recrudescence de
personnes abandonnant leurs chiens parce
qu'ils s'aperçoivent que l'animal coup
toulon revient trop cher
nous avons réalisé une étude récemment
c'est-à-dire en mars 91
cette étude dont le nom et le cou du
chien dans le foyer français fait
ressortir des points très significatif
au total 1 foyers dépensent 2500 francs
pour le chien qui se ventilant
différents postes l'alimentation 4500
francs les frais de dressage 500 francs
les frais de toilettage environ 1000
francs et quelques divers je vous passe
les détails
donc au total 2500 francs contre à titre
de référence 11 850 francs pour un
enfant en moyenne
bien sûr cette étude a été faite sur un
échantillon de 1000 foyers toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles
confondues
comme leurs maîtres les chiens vivent de
plus en plus dans les agglomérations
urbaines qu'ils occasionnent par là même
l'achat de toute une gamme de produits
canin qui n'existaient pas autrefois et
grève de plus en plus le budget
domestique conserve gastronomique soins
corporels joujou et gadgets divers
[Musique]
l'amour qu'ils veulent manifester pour
leur animal quel qu'il soit est
proportionnelle aux efforts que qu'il
veut le faire ils veulent absolument
l'impossible même plus que l'impossible
vraiment pour manger je ferais n'importe
quoi parce qu'elle fait partie de moi
même
cela en france à ses enfants sanofi nous
avons des gens qui font des familles
complète et parfaite où il ya papa maman
de deux enfants est le troisième enfant
est un animal puisse de france à peu
près la même chose pour mon fils que
pour chiens j'aimerais bien voir comment
il habille et son fils alors la première
année les gens en moyenne dépense plus
pour leurs chiens que pour leur enfant s
de l'info s de la tête cette fois de
jouer aux cow
je crois que malheureusement c'est de
l'info ouais mais toi et te clos alors
si l'intox
tu dis que c'est de l'intox et ben
j'aurais pas voir comment les enfants
sera but
bon on va voir d'écouter un expert
filipe vieira il va nous le dire comme
ça alors avant que vous finissez bien la
soirée désolé cloclo vous finissez mal
la soirée puisque c'est de l'intox
ah et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu